[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce numéro de vie pour aujourd'hui
j'ai le plaisir de recevoir Dimitri de
la rocklatour il est déjà venu sur notre
plateau et il y a même Séville à très
très longtemps vous racontera tout ça il
sort aujourd'hui un livre qui s'appelle
la France fantastique dans la collection
voyage chez Gallimard voilà ce livre il
est là et Dimitri et tvinois vient nous
le présenter Dimitri bonjour bonjour
Véronique merci d'être sur notre plateau
de tv78 il y a très très longtemps quand
vous étiez étudiant vous aviez même une
émission qui s'appelait tête à tête si
je ne m'abuse oui exactement
des interviews avec des personnalités
différents de culture de l'information
dizaine de minutes pour évoquer le
parcours et TV 78 était votre média
votre canal en fait
vous êtes engagé dans des études
d'histoire voilà vous avez et puis aussi
vous aviez une passion parallèlement la
photographie alors ce livre justement il
est le fruit de beaucoup d'années de
travail en fait on peut dire ça comment
vous le présentez ce livre c'est un
guide
mais à la différence de d'autres guides
et ça c'est tout le pari de cette
collection voyage gallima c'est ce guide
sont en réalité des beaux livres ils
sont conçus avec une une imagerie et
vous avez vu des cartes qui superposent
des photos magnifiques et là c'est tout
le travail du Bureau des Affaires
graphiques donc une agence Cécile
Bernier colerto qui a beaucoup travaillé
et de mon côté j'ai apporté la matière
effectivement de de on va dire une vraie
vie
vous avez vous êtes aussi photographe
voilà et ce qui vous attire c'est un
monde bien particulier c'est le monde
des faits des légendes des elfes des
ruines et des châteaux hantés alors ça
ça je le dois donc à mon grand oncle
Jacques de la d'où ça vient cette
passion c'est le peintre de la Dame
Blanche laby de Mortemer alors
mystérieuses évidemment l'abbaye morte
mère apparaît comme le lieu symbolique
vous dites que c'est le château le plus
hanté de France elle est où il y a le
logis à Bastia il y a l'héroïnes de
l'abbaye elle est en Normandie pas très
loin de Rouen une vingtaine de minutes
de Rouen au cœur de la forêt de Lyon qui
parle même et la être une être elle vous
savez le être l'arbre des fées
et cet abbaye est tenté donc par
Mathilde lamperet ce qui est une figure
historique petite fille enfin grand-mère
plutôt de Richard cœur de lion donc elle
a une une réalité là était la
bienfaitrice de l'abbaye et depuis sa
mort donc elle revient les nuits de
pleine lune si on la voit avec un gant
noir c'est signe de mort dans l'année
pour le malheureux son entourage avec un
gant blanc de naissance donc il y a
cette cette
ambiguïté quand j'étais petit vous
imaginez on arrive dans cette année dans
l'abbaye nous avons nos passions de
vacances à une vingtaine de minutes et
ce qui fait qu'à
vacances que ça soit l'hiver l'été je je
voulais absolument c'était une obsession
d'aller voir l'abbaye de Mortemer et
pour s'y rendre on passait par un récit
de route tout d'un coup des routes
droites forestières très très longue et
surtout on voyait le j'avais
l'impression que le piège allait se
refermer les arbres la vitesse faisait
que les arbres s'allongaient j'essayais
de voir dans le paysage et je voyais la
dame blanche en espérant la voir en
redoutant aussi son gant la couleur donc
tout ça crée une comme un périple
initiatique et évidemment l'abbaye de
Mortemer il y a le musée des légendes et
des fantômes de France
toute une scénographie on arrive dans
des salles il y a des musiques qui
s'enclenchent et de lumière et les
tableaux de de mon aïeul donc vous
imaginez aussi cette cette
familiarité en somme avec le lieu et
avec son l'esprit du lieu comme vous
l'avez vu peut-être je crois qu'elle m'a
vu moi je ne vais je
mets à force d'y avoir été je pense
qu'elle elle m'a pas montré la couleur
de son gant je ne crois pas en tout cas
pour l'instant c'est mort pour l'instant
comme on dit parfois ce sont les marines
qui se penchent sur le berceau des
enfants dans mon cas c'est en tout cas
moi qui est désiré à percevoir cette
cette dame blanche ça marche pas dans ce
cas là je crois vous croyez pas c'est
elle qui doit vouloir vous voir bref on
y croit encore on sait jamais ce livre
lui est dédié voilà
l'initiatrice du de l'oeuvre voilà après
vous êtes aussi allé photographier
d'autres pays vite fait c'est pour ça
qu'on vous avait reçu pour une
exposition les cosses et vous êtes
toujours aussi friand de ces ambiances
ses lumières particulières
qui est un autre projet l'appel de
Merlin et oui les lumières c'est vrai
que dans ces pays celtes je dirais
presque la lumière fait du bruit elle
est tellement elle change très
rapidement il y a des il y a une une
harmonie on entend presque le bruit de
l'art à la limite on l'entendrait
presque en France évidemment les régions
qui se rapprochent de ces paysages et
qui ont ma préférence imagine norm
Bretagne on somme les régions du nord de
la Loire au sud ces différences quand
même plus minéral il a la Tarasque du
côté du Rhône il y a la brownia du côté
du Périgord dont parle aussi Gérard de
Nerval dans dans Aurelia et là aussi
dans le livre on croise parfois Gérard
de Nerval qui est un autre qui est le
grand arpenteur de la France des
légendes alors là vous avez un peu
répertorié donc tous ces lieux propices
à ces ambiances alors il faut on a
l'impression qu'il faut des ruines il
faut il faut de l'eau faut de la forêt
faut de la brume donc forcément les
lieux du Nord sont plus humides et plus
propices et quels sont les lieux les
régions de France avec les lieux les oh
pardon dont les oh on trouve les lieux
les plus hantés bah c'était dur à sortir
évidemment alors la Bretagne est
particulièrement un lieu que j'ai
découvert l'année dernière on parle
souvent de la forêt de Brocéliande du
côté de Paimpont qui a malheureusement
d'ailleurs un parti brûlée cet été mais
du côté de Locronan qui est l'autre
montagne une montagne magique le bois de
Locronan le Ménez le corne et il y a là
des pleins de petits arbres au départ
qui sont assez tordus qui sont tout à
fait imaginaires de tolken et la
véritablement j'ai eu l'impression il
était midi en plus une heure
généralement où les faits peuvent
apparaître ça c'est dans les oui oui
c'est midi et minuit
de transition et là j'ai véritablement
cru dans cette forêt avec une petite qui
est gardée par une fontaine à l'entrée
évidemment miraculeuse l'ancienne
fontaine drudit qui est devenu
chrétienne et midi et j'ai cru que je ne
pourrais jamais sortir de ce lieu
tellement j'y étais
bien c'est ça tous les lieux dans ce
livre sont des lieux certes hantés avec
des phénomènes c'est quelque chose mais
ce sont pas des lieux maléfiques
généralement bénéfique il nous coupe
d'une réalité et si vous voulez c'est un
peu comme quand on a une crampe on a
l'impression qu'il y a quelque chose qui
est figé en nous et que on a peur de
bouger on a peur de on met ensuite quand
on sort de celui-là un certain temps
pour retrouver ce réadapter à une
certaine
réalité on a peur de casser la magie oui
oui et puis on se sent peut-être un
petit peu prisonnier comme un chat c'est
le charme de Viviane exercée sur Merlin
par exemple est-ce qu'il y a des lieux
où vous avez vraiment ressenti ce
quelque chose de physique
oui je dirais que c'est après
au moment d'autant plus que comme j'ai
en plus peut-être c'est ce qui me sauve
une quête photographique
je suis c'est à dire je suis enchanté je
suis je m'enivre des lumières qui
passent donc je suis très
euphorique quand je suis sur le lieu en
revanche après et notamment au château
de Chantilly au château de l'argouët le
tour d'Elven en Bretagne aussi c'était
en plus en octobre novembre vraiment à
la période de sa main nous voyait de là
où la saison sombre commence chez les
Celtes et j'en suis revenu et quelques
jours après j'ai été très marqué par ces
lieux j'avais des périodes pas très pas
très amusante pour le coup je me suis
dit que j'avais peut-être emporter avec
moi quelque chose bizarre après c'est
passé vous voyez c'est on emporte des
choses du lieu parfois je comprends
alors donc dans ce livre vous avez
répertorié tous vos lieux qui à vous
vous sont chers et sont
donc en thé habité voilà même ne
serait-ce que pour les décors etc vous
avez une façon aussi très très concrète
de c'est un guide en général vous y
allez même à chaque fois vous y allez à
pied en transport en commun donc on vous
expliquer quel bus prendre quel train
etc vous vous plantez un décor vous
racontez la légende qui en général tous
ces lieux sont basés sur des enfin on a
l'impression que les gens sont forcément
des drames comme si le lieu avait la
mémoire des drames et oui et c'est
souvent des des histoires affreuses très
cruelles très cruelle oui donc il y a
beaucoup de
soirs magiques magnifiques vous racontez
à chaque lieu on peut dire que la
revanche aussi du lieu et les histoires
sont cruelles et les fantômes évidemment
apparaissent à ce moment-là il y a
parfois aussi le génie bienveillant mais
disons ces lieux ont une image
romantique dans l'ensemble vous voyez
quand ce sont des châteaux il s'est
passé des choses et pouvant tables des
crimes les voir oui puis les voir tomber
en ruine on a l'impression que la fleur
qui pousse abolie un petit peu le drame
ici jouer les oiseaux chantent les
enfants viennent jouer au milieu des des
ruines donc il y a il y a une
bénédiction qui a apporté par par le
concile formule magique il faut quand
même pas oublier de prononcer Harum
makulatum
la plante de serpent la fleur des
repères et que vous prononcez en cas de
sortilège pour vous prévenir non c'était
c'était un petit peu un remède oui c'est
important si vous avez en Alsace
pittoresque comme ça
et quand vous voyez quand vous arrivez
dans un lieu que vous connaissez la
réputation des serpents et vous voyez
certaines de ces plantes qui ont les
globules orange manquent vous dites que
d'autres esprits sont passés par là
avant vous c'est mort mais seriez-vous
chez à Dimitri atteint de Paris de lit
par hasard ah l'appareil de lit c'est le
fait de voir alors voir avec toutes les
vues qu'on peut avoir mais dans
certaines dans les nuages par exemple
dans les rochers qui ont des des qui se
ressemblent évidemment ou les les
feuilles les frondaisons de voir
apparaître des visages généralement
c'est c'est le sens de
en latin idolone ce sont des apparences
et alors là évidemment les scientifiques
vont dire mais ce sont des effets de
physique
tout ce que veut les poètes diront non
c'est un signe des dieux c'est une c'est
une présence cette bon là je ne pense
pas la magie quand on est sensible à ça
même les enfants voient des
nuits dans leur chambre le rideau il y a
une tête de Mons cachée parce que ces
trois plis qui font
donc on peut on peut subir le même
phénomène dans ces lieux sombres et faut
pas y aller alors s'il faut y aller à
midi il faut y aller le soir
en vérité si une question je pense de
sensibilité comme on pour dire un petit
peu un peu lourdement de longueur d'onde
mais si justement on arrive en vous
parliez des enfants qui sont capables de
faire des combinaisons avec des cailloux
des choses qui entre dans ce monde là je
crois que tout est une question d'entrée
par l'intermédiaire d'une lecture d'un
conte alors justement on lit ce livre et
puis on est tout de suite mis en
condition déjà ça nous imprègne bien de
la magie du lieu d'avoir l'histoire en
tête toutes ces légendes que vous êtes
allés sourcer au plus profond des des
greniers des grimoises des manoir hantés
ou vous avez failli beaucoup de courage
je crois aussi et donc ça ça nous
prépare bien à la visite en fait c'est
on est plongé d'avance dans dans ce
qu'on va on espère retrouver et même le
14 lui a une vision qui est sourcée
d'ailleurs qui est racontée c'est cela
c'était près d'ici dans la forêt de
Fontainebleau
ce qui lui avait été dit Louis XVI aussi
aura eu cette vision quelques quelques
mots en tout cas oui quelques mois
c'est un géant c'était un on l'appelle
le grand éleveur ce sont les les
chasseurs de les bûcherons dans votre
Rambouillet qu'il l'appelle le grand
veneur parce qu'il a une allure de de
d'homme sauvage tout en noir et son
apparition n'est effectivement souvent
de mauvaises augure
et bah faut se repose qui est tout près
d'ici dans les Yvelines Meudon toutes
ces forêts là sont sont on leur lieu on
peut juste donner le recommandation pour
les promeneurs ne surtout pas marcher
sur l'herbe d'or qui a été semé par les
druides assez longtemps et qui pousse
toujours et cette plante fait perdre
tout de suite l'orientation le sens de
l'orientation
donc ça la formule et puis si on n'a pas
tout retenu on peut vous retrouver le 26
novembre on est en novembre 26 novembre
chez Gibert Joseph à Versailles
l'après-midi vous avez une autre
signature à la
canal 50 ans à Montigny ouais et puis
troisième chose bientôt une exposition
château Voltaire qui se trouve alors
c'est dans l'Ain vous avez un site.com
je suis le mieux je crois bien sûr on
peut me trouver très facilement voilà
Dimitri la tour un grand merci pour
cette présence et à très vite pour un
prochain ouvrage ou d'autres
photographies qui sait avec grand
plaisir merci Dimitri au revoir à tous
merci de nous avoir suivi à bientôt
[Musique]